[Music]
foreign
okay concept phones the marketing
machine strikes again so all right
OnePlus has been hyping up and teasing
this concept phone with these images for
the past week or so by the time you see
this it's looking pretty spicy it's got
a lot of people wondering about it
meanwhile I've been testing the phone
for about three weeks now this is the
actual phone now again the fact that
it's a concept phone means it's not
coming out anytime soon like it doesn't
have any true parallel to a current
OnePlus Zone but it's meant to
demonstrate something cool or unique
that they're just not shipping and so
with this one it's an active cooling
system that they're calling cryoflux
technology active cryoflux is what it
says on the back
uh so you can see it I think it actually
looks super sick if you look closely at
the back of the phone here you can see
this icy blue liquid pulsing through
these channels over the back and it's
over the hottest parts of the phone it's
keeping the battery and the CPU and GPU
cool and then it's around the camera
bump too you can see it up here flowing
around this circle around the
multi-camera system I'm not sure liquid
flowing around the camera bump would
actively contribute to Cooling in a
useful way but it sure does look sick
it's hard to appreciate it fully on
camera but just holding it in my hands
looking at it especially if you go into
a darker room you can see these bubbles
that make it clear that there's some
type of liquid running over the back of
the phone the only thing is uh it
doesn't work
like at all like this like all the stuff
that I said that it would be cool if it
did like cooling a CPU and GPU and
Battery it doesn't actually do that like
it does have the liquid flowing through
the channels to make it look like it's
cooling things but this doesn't actively
contribute to the cooling in this phone
just looks like it does so this concept
phone is designed to show the
possibilities of what a working version
of this could look like or maybe an
exaggerated version of this could look
like but that's just it it's just what
it could look like so okay what if it
did really work well OnePlus told me
that uh they believe a future version of
cryoflux that is actually working uh
would reduce the phone's charging
temperature by 1.6 degrees Celsius which
would allow it to charge from zero to
100 up to one minute faster
and reduce gaming temperatures by up to
2.1 degrees Celsius which could
translate to an extra two to four frames
per second
and that's what they told me so that's
like that's probably the absolute best
case optimistic version of what they got
in their testing basically there's a
good reason why this is showing up in a
concept phone and not in an actual real
shipping phone which is like this adds a
lot of complexity and potentially cost
and thickness obviously you have the
liquid and the pumps and everything not
that this is like a super thick phone
but it adds thickness all for not a ton
of benefit this is very concept phone
thing to do like we do have the Asus Rog
phone and the Lenovo Legion dual I don't
know if you remember that phone these
are some of the only phones in the world
that I've seen that have actually tried
real active Cooling and even that was
different it wasn't cryoflux it was like
a fan accessory that plugs into the back
these phones sacrifice water resistance
and thinness and their expensive Niche
phones but they did it so why show this
off if you're not actually intending on
making it into an actual phone you're
going to ship and sell well the answer
like so many other things with a lot of
these companies is marketing right so
these companies do spend a lot of money
on R D on research and development and
they're constantly coming up with new
ideas that get proposed and then mocked
up and then prototyped and tested and
adjusted and a lot of these things end
up making it into a phone but the ones
that don't they don't make it to the end
maybe they just get repackaged and
turned into a nice concept for people to
admire their hard work and then they
don't actually make it to a phone it's
kind of like how we're pretty sure we
can be confident that somewhere in
Apple's headquarters there is an iPhone
with USBC just for testing there's no
way they haven't tested it yet at this
point but they're not going to turn
around and and packaging it up and
showing it off as a concept phone it
would be kind of funny if they did
actually but that's something they keep
under the surface but the companies that
do this concept phone thing this is
really just about getting a little bit
of PR return little positive marketing
return for all the dollars that you
spend on research and development that
didn't end up making it into final
products that you could eventually
Market as if they were going to be in
customers hands which is fine I can't
really be mad at that but at the same
time I'm holding like I'm holding a cool
idea that's not going to be a real
feature in a phone so I put together a
little list of concept phones just so
you can see what we're working with here
and I've put them in order of worst to
best based on how much I wanted them to
become a real thing so in 2020 OnePlus
did another concept phone they're no
stranger to these this is a phone with a
color changing back uh it could change
colors for fun or even as a notification
indicator using electrochromic glass the
reason it never came to a real phone is
because electrochromic glass is insanely
expensive and difficult to make
efficient in a tiny smartphone but your
phone could change colors then this year
there was a xiaomi concept phone based
on the 12s Ultra that let you attach a
physical like a lens to the back of the
camera system on the phone cool idea to
be able to attach and use different high
quality lenses for different focal
lengths on the back of your phone but
the fact is you're still extremely
limited by the one inch smartphone
sensor underneath and by the time you
put all that extra Hardware up and
you're carrying around several lenses
most people would rather just carry a
regular good camera that's going to take
great pictures with a larger sensor
anyway
then there's TCL TCL also is no stranger
to console phones and they brought one
to CES this year with a paper-like matte
display this is kind of interesting it's
like a Kindle kind of cool idea I
actually love the thought of having a
full color but fully fingerprint lists
and reflection free display on a phone
uh but this one isn't coming to a real
phone either because well TCL isn't sure
if there's going to be enough people
interested in it and also people who
actually got to use it also noticed the
Finish does take a big hit to the
brightness overall and there will also
be some durability questions too with a
normal smartphone with regular glass you
can go to Corning and buy their best
hardest strongest Gorilla Glass and
that's typically fine but with this you
couldn't buy some off-the-shelf strong
glass so you don't know it might be a
little bit brittle it might be a little
bit scratch prone that's the type of
thing that they're worried about now
Vivo did a concept phone in 2019 with no
buttons and no ports it had thick
pressure sensitive areas around the body
and Pogo pins for charging and data
instead of a port that's not what I
liked about it though what I liked was
it also had a full screen under display
fingerprint reader so instead of it
having to be in this like specific area
right in the bottom of the Middle where
you have to nail it every time might
take more than one try on this concept
you can literally unlock with your
fingerprint by just touching anywhere on
the screen which is kind of crazy this
is an evolution of what they did back
with the first Apex concept phone which
was in 2018 which was a bezel-less
concept with a pop-up camera and a half
screen fingerprint sensor I just like
the idea of being able to add more than
one finger at once for extra security
that would have been super sick but yeah
an optical sensor that big is extremely
extremely expensive way too expensive
for a phone
now OnePlus also did a concept phone at
CES 2020 that I thought was really
interesting it used electrochromic glass
again so hey too expensive but this time
is to darken or lighten just the glass
over the rear camera and it was cool it
could hide it if you went all the way
dark and it had this Sleek look but also
it could be used as a sort of an ND
shade for reducing the amount of light
that gets in so taking pictures Outdoors
or in bright light again it would have
been cool to see but that Tech is just
not efficient enough to miniaturize and
put in smartphones right now so that
McLaren Edition concept phone is never
going to happen and then maybe the most
interesting concept phone of them all is
the all these the foldable rollable
crazy stuff that we've seen from several
companies so TCL did a fold and roll
with like an accordion hinge back in the
day when that was the only way anyone
knew how to do it Motorola though did a
rollable concept phone that actually
extends its height from the top like a
match trick and LG did a rollable phone
that extended in the landscape Direction
rip to LG but all these Concepts you
guessed it never shipped or never turned
into real phones or real products of
course for various reliability and cost
reasons that make perfect sense so at
this point it feels like we have the
formula for how a concept phone is born
like how A Star is Born in the universe
which is like all right spend a lot of
money on research and development and
various ideas will make it all the way
through the prototyping stage and get
into the final product which is cool
some of them won't make it quite to the
end
but we can still repackage them into a
concept phone and show off how cool it
could be
and I guess on one hand I can't really
be salty that they're spending a lot of
energy on new research and development
it's cool that we get new ideas but then
also yeah concept phone kind of just a
just a PR stunt at the end of the day
why not both
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]